[MUSIC PLAYING]
DINO CHIESA: Dino here.
I'm with Apigee, which
is part of Google Cloud.
This video is Apigee 101.
We'll learn how
to create a proxy
and begin serving traffic.
Let's dive in.
After you've created your trial
account, sign in to apigee.com.
Click the API proxies icon and
you'll see the proxies list.
Now, in your
organization, you may
see one or more API proxies.
What we want to do
is create a new one.
We'll do that with the wizard.
From within the wizard,
first select reverse proxy.
We'll name the proxy,
specify a base path--
I'll say more about
that in a moment--
and specify the backend target.
This is what the
proxy will connect to.
For this demonstration,
we'll use a public API
that returns a JSON payload.
Then we specify our
security requirements.
For now, we will
have no security.
Specify the virtual
hosts on which
this proxy will be active.
I prefer the TLS-enabled v host.
Specify the environment,
test for now.
Done.
This proxy is now active,
ready to handle traffic.
Let's click through
to the proxy editor
to see the overview of
the proxy we just created.
We can see all the
details we provided.
Also, we can see the URL where
we can invoke this API proxy.
Let's try it.
Just click this URL and it
opens in another browser tab,
and we can see the JSON
returned by the proxy,
so the proxy is working.
Let's flip back to the
Apigee administrative UI.
Clicking the
Develop tab gives us
the chance to modify the
proxy produced by the wizard.
I can change the deployment
status of the proxy,
undeploy it, at which point
it won't be listening anymore.
I can change any of the
choices I made previously.
And I can configure
additional policies that
will run for each
inbound request
before the request is
proxied to the target,
or policies that run on the
response after the response is
received from the
target but before it
is sent to the original client.
Apigee proxies are
smart and configurable.
Let's add a rate-limiting
policy to this proxy, a quota
enforcement.
To do that, I'll click the
preflow in the proxy endpoint
and click the plus step icon.
Here I see a list of
the various policies
Apigee Edge has available.
I want the quota policy.
Let's configure it with a fixed
rate limit of three requests
for every minute.
To do that, I'll just paste
in some simple configuration.
Then I'll save it
and redeploy it.
And then, flipping back
to the other browser tab,
I can invoke it again.
Now, there's no change in the
behavior of this API proxy.
It's still returning JSON.
But after I invoke that
proxy more than three times,
I get an error that says the
rate limit has been exceeded.
The Apigee proxy is
rejecting the request
because it's
exceeding the limit.
Rate limiting is easy.
Flipping back to the
Apigee administrative UI,
in the Develop tab, let me
raise that limit to, oh, 1,000
requests per minute.
I can do it just like that.
But surely there are other
options for the quota policy.
How do I learn about them?
By selecting the policy
in the API proxy editor,
I can get a hyperlink
that takes me
to the documentation
for that policy.
Here I can learn
everything I need
to know about how to use the
quota policy, super helpful.
If you have questions
that are not
answered by the documentation,
you can visit the community.
Find the link to the
community in the Apigee
administrative UI.
Search there or
ask a new question.
Friendly Apigee experts
like me are always there,
willing to help you out.
In this video, you
learned the basics
of Apigee Edge, how
to create an API proxy
and how to add a
policy to a proxy, how
to find documentation
on a policy
and how to navigate to
the Apigee community.
In the next video, we'll cover
how to add API key verification
to an existing proxy.
Until then, I wish
you strong API mojo.
[MUSIC PLAYING]